hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
we'll be talking about uh one of the
changes in orderflows Trader 7 uh that
deals with Delta divergences um that I
think can um you know have a good
positive effect on your trading but
before I jump in you know if you
appreciate my videos be sure to
subscribe to the channel so when I post
new videos which I hopefully will be
doing as soon as I recover from this bad
uh flu or or cold it's it's definitely
not Co because I've tested twice already
for Co and it's not Co but it's just uh
knocking me out that's why I haven't
been able to get many videos out
recently um you know we've recently
released the orderflows trader 7 and
we've made some nice changes that I
think can help a lot of Traders so what
I want to talk about today is the Delta
Divergence and that's these gold areas
on the chart okay so in the indicator
setting um let's just pull it up here
and take a look so you can see here
Delta Divergence right right it's
enabled and in the past what
we had always drawn the Delta Divergence
at is appearing at the high of the day
or the low of the day because when you
would have a Delta Divergence you would
have a new or equal high with negative
Delta that would be a bearish Delta
Divergence or a bullish Delta Divergence
would be a new or equal low with
positive Delta and we took it a step
further because you know if you're
looking for a reversal which you know if
you're looking at divergences
you are looking for the market to
reverse itself so what you also want to
see is the price action in the bar so if
you're going to be looking for a bearish
Delta Divergence you're going to need a
newer equal high with negative Delta and
a red candle or for a bullish Delta
Divergence right you're going to need a
new or equal
low with positive
Delta with a green candle so you see
here right the green candle positive
Delta on the on the new low or here the
um red Candle on the new high with the
negative Delta
and here was the Delta Divergence okay
as well so there there are going to be
times where you have Delta divergences
like here or here sometimes you know if
you're just looking at a Delta
Divergence by itself and trying to trade
it by itself I think that's kind of a
recipe for disaster because you know
especially in a trending Market you know
if a market is moving in One Direction
based on off of you know just strong
directional flow you know everyone's
piling in into the market um you can get
run over right and because you're going
to see some divergences and really all
it is is just people taking money off
the table that they're taking profits
okay so one of the ways that I've always
advocated for the last 10 years you know
if you've watched my videos since I
first released the software is when you
have a Divergence with a bullish ratio
right here 0. 61 or a bearish ratio
right here 136 the ratios are going to
appear above or below the bar okay and
with the orderflows trader
7 okay it's going to appear any bullish
ratio will appear below a green candle
that meets certain requirement so you
can see this bar here no longer has a
ratio it just has normal order flow in
the past we used to actually draw the
the ratio number there it would just be
a black color but that was confusing
some people so they asked us hey can you
um not show us the ratios that don't
matter just show us the ratios that
matter like here and here here here here
right up here here here and what we
found a decade ago right and we've been
teaching Traders this for the last 10
years Traders are still using it is when
you have a Divergence and a ratio
that's a good trade setup because what
is a ratio there's two types of ratios
there's a ratio bonds High there's a
ratio bonds low ratio bounds High
indicates price exhaustion ratio bounds
low indicates price defense so you have
price exhaustion or Price defense okay
and so imagine right Market runs up from
the low all the way up to a new high
okay you have a Divergence here maybe
this is just some profit taking here if
Market comes down couple of ticks then
reverses goes up to new highs now we
have a ratio balance High which
indicates price exhaustion so now what
do I got well I know I've got some
strong selling cuz I got negative Delta
okay so I got negative Delta at a new
high but based on the ratio the 136
again it doesn't matter what to me what
the ratio is as long as it's a red
number on
top to me that is a signal okay so I
know I got price exhaustion so after a
move up I got price exhaustion coming in
at the high not only that but I got
aggressive sellers coming in because I
know I got negative Delta that's what's
causing the um Divergence right the
negative Delta at the new high okay
now so you can see like you know this
morning this this morning I say this
morning this was last night at at 11:46
and up until this morning here at 7:45
there's a beautiful move from the low
all the way up to these new highs
finally you get this signal just going
back to yesterday
um well there was that one at 9:00 but
uh you know there was a little buy here
the night
before Market went from the low up to
the high now what we've done with the
new version of orderflows Trader 7 is
we've given you now the
ability
to look at swing highs and swing lows
with
divergences Okay so let's just go here
to the Delta Divergence I'll enable the
swing filter okay I'll disable the daily
high and daily low so now it's going to
show
me divergences at swing highs and swing
lows as opposed to just at the high of
the day and the low of the
day okay so here now I got another
Divergence coming in here okay but ratio
there it's just a just a
Divergence um the day before here
right excuse me now I've got
Divergence plus a bullish ratio of price
exhaustion so I know the market sold off
from a swing high or in this case the
high of the day down to the swing low
there's some price exhaustion and then
aggressive buying is coming in so you
couple the price exhaustion with you
know in price exhaustion in this case is
the aggressive sellers are getting
weaker and the aggressive buyers are
getting stronger well if the aggressive
sellers are getting weaker and the
aggressive buyers are getting stronger
chances are the Market's going to go
higher which it did up to new highs here
okay hit the high of the day no
Divergence it's a bearish ratio then it
came down here to a swing
low right 135 it's telling me so it's a
bullish ratio similar thing that
happened here it's happening right here
you've got a
Divergence you've got price
exhaustion the aggressive buyers are
stepping in Market moves up to new highs
now this trade and this trade would not
have appeared right if you're only
looking at divergences on swing highs or
swing lows so for example I'll just show
you right if I'm just looking
at Delta Divergence only on swing high
and swing
low right that trade's not there there
that trade's not
there because it's only looking for
divergences at the highs or lows of the
days and imagine you know that just
opens up a whole
new layer of trades for you because now
you could be looking at swing highs and
swing
lows now another thing that uh you know
again you know for some Traders it's you
know try to watch and and see
these you know that's all they do they
just sit there and watch it and just you
know one little trick that some Traders
do to make it a little bit easier to
make it stand out more is under the
order flows
ratios um what they do is they draw
out the Zone either fixed one which
would highlight this whole area around
the ratio or they're going to draw it
out until
tested and it's just easier when you see
the the red
zone buted right up next against to the
um yellow or the blue like this one
right here right up against the yellow
here right it's just stands out more
here okay
here
so you know again that's just one of the
the little changes that we've made
here's a nice bearish
one to a bullish one um here's a bearish
one
here it's a bearish one that just went
sideways on you I mean it came off a
little bit one sideways made a new high
and then sideways
again but there was a bearish one that
went
nowhere so again you know hopefully you
can see the possibilities now of looking
at not just Delta Divergence at the
highs and lows of the day but the
importance of looking at them at swing
highs and swing lows okay there's no
rule that says the Delta Divergence can
only appear at a swing high or a swing
low of course not Delta Divergence
occurs when there's a new or equal High
it doesn't have to be high the day could
be a swing high or a new equal low it
could be a swing low
okay so again you know I hope that's
going to get a few Traders thinking you
know how they could use this in their
own trading and benefit from it because
they know that that's at the end of the
day all orderflow is it's data right and
what orderflows Trader does is it puts
the
data into an easyto read format so that
you can understand what's taking place
in the market all right guys I'm going
to go my my throat's about to uh to give
out on me here but um again you know if
you enjoy this video be sure to like it
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
and I'll catch you guys on the next
video take
care